another year around the Sun as creepy
Joe turns 81 today President Biden
turned 81 years old and he celebrated
with a fresh bottle of embalming
fluid I'm kidding they actually sang
Happy birthday to him and by the way I
it's my birthday today and they can
actually sang
birthday I just want you to know it's
difficult turning
difficult
well I think Joe knows all about turning
60 he's done it three
times but after that song Joe stripped
down and had the Press Play connect the
liver spots with their
Sharpies but Bloomberg News calls his
age his biggest liability for
2024 you know if you don't count Hunter
the open border the bad economy the war
in Ukraine the war in Israel the botched
Afghanistan withdrawal the rising crime
rate payoffs from China and of course
the the price of gas and eggs meanwhile
Politico reports quote even those in
Biden's Inner Circle including family
members worry about the Optics of age
some acknowledge that the president can
at times appear
frail can at times appear frail that's
an understatement he's so frail dust
comes out when he
pees he's so frail he broke his hip
reading the Wall Street Journal called
his running for re-election an act of
profound selfishness quote aging people
even if they're not surrounded by yes
men can be the last to notice times tall
yeah especially when these yes men say
yes to everything Joe says except did I
myself and in Biden's case his aging
brain can't tell the difference between
a six-year-old girl and a teenager
behold oh my God I love your ears oh my
God love them they're really cool what's
your name Catherine Catherine what a
beautiful name that's my mommy's name
well nice to see how old are you
17 she six
six you know that's the kind of mistake
that gets most men 15 to
20 or a seat on Jeffrey Epstein's
private
jet so what do you get the man who has
it all yet remembers nothing
well let's see what his Pal's got him
you'll never guess what kamla got Joe
for his birthday check it out
huh my
God and for the eighth year in a row
here's what Hunter got
him his brother got him the usual
money the girls in the secretarial pool
got him some some new sniffing
material Dr Jill got him a special card
he's supposed to keep in his
wallet the crew of Air Force One got him
this for the next time he tries to
board and finally those Chief skate
Taliban all they got them was this
card you know Emily I think it's I think
it's a bad thing for Republicans to
focus on age because that gives them a
free pass on everything else I'm
literally I'm literally crying from his
birthday presence right now okay I don't
ever want to bash anyone's age because
may you live until 120 God bless you a I
agree it's our
audience just you don't you don't have
to run for president but you know what
it is his birthday so I actually wrote a
little letter for Biden that I'd like to
share happy birthday president may you
live until 120 may you have another year
of single-handedly ruining the economy
uh creating a new term called B
inflation which I use every single day
now opening our borders welcoming so
many new friends and Hamas terrorists
and last but not least for
single-handedly sending billions to Iran
to keep up the terror thank you so much
Mr President happy
birthday you know Jim I made this point
on the five and nobody laughed so I'm
going to say it to you it's funny when
you see because Trump is not much
younger than Joe but meanwhile Trump is
doing standup while Joe can barely stand
up thank you got to laugh
here that's okay I said that to I said
that to uh to what's that guy uh who
sits in Jesse and he's just nodded he
wasn't even
listening anyway was there a mirror
nearby yes there was a
mirror what do you think about his
birthday um you
know he's old I
mean they're saying like a lot of people
are worried like what if there a
national security threat in the middle
of the night how'll be able to handle it
he's 81 MH he's getting up 10 times a
night going to the bathroom yes he's
going to be fine if anyone's going to be
awake it's going to be him that's true
that's
true but I mean I got a idea like you
know John F Kennedy was 43 when he was
sworn in right so Joe Biden if he gets
the second nomination he'll be 86 when
he's out of office so the Biden teams
are just go Hey listen you're not going
to vote in one old man you're going to
vote in two JFK
that might work that might work that
might work I don't know if it will
Kennedy uh what do you think of this
like the age thing is the age the worst
thing about Joe no there are people
turning a hundred left and right I mean
there are people who are in their 90s
and close to 100 who are running circles
around him point is yeah Steve duy is
117 years old it is incredible man is up
at 2:00 in the morning single-handedly
running this network yes he's so Sprite
he's he's too important here we can't
let him go R the country yes but yeah
Joe Biden it's it's the fact that he's
in mental decline that is never going to
reverse itself like he he's never going
to be spry he's never going to remember
things he's never going to have his
former strength so the Wall Street
Journal is right it is an act of
selfishness it's also an act of Cruelty
you know the the yes men and women that
you talk about they're the ones who are
propping him up he's incredibly stubborn
he's been to the summit anyone who has
been been president never wants to give
away that power and they're letting him
and shame on them he should have the
wisdom to step aside but he can't CU KLA
is horrible yeah that's exactly right
and less popular than he is KLA is his
insurance plan right you know I heard
that like Joe actually applied for a
balance of nature commercial and they
said
no relax him though relax
him sleepy joke and one or two bottles
of
those Charlie uh they keep talking about
this bubble wrap uh strategy like the
the the analogy of just wrapping him in
bubble wrap what could that mean well I
mean it it I think it's an admission
that I mean it's not going to get better
from here yeah and I agree with you uh
you know his age is probably his least
terrible liability but it is a it is a a
problem um and it's it's you know is he
going to fall less yeah as as time goes
ha it's only going to get worse and I
don't think that Donald Trump is going
if Trump winds up being the nominee I
don't think that he's going to um let
him get away with doing trying the whole
the basement strategy but uh you know
carrying on with what uh Kennedy said
you know it is it is absolutely selfish
but it's also two levels of selfishness
it's not just his own selfishness and
his own self-regard but it's also he's
like surrounded by family who are like
still making money off of him that's
true and they have to prop him up and
they and it's the mo it's the cruelest
thing I feel like we've ever seen in in
recent politics yeah I'm trying it's
like having like a an Entertainer in
your family who's really old and so you
just wheel him out and try for the fans
and then you just take the money you
take the money like Liza Manelli
remember that on that was that that the
Oscars when Lady Gaga wheeled her out
and it was really sad am I doing a show
right
now he's it's like he's their ATM
machine yeah he's their ATM machine yeah
except things come out out of him wait
Greg I didn't know three different
places I didn't know when you meant
bubble wrap analogy I thought you
literally meant physically wrapping it
on him he fall so much and then I was
like oh that actually would make that's
only when they move him all right up
next gen Z wants a pass for sitting on
their ass hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else